so for first spaceforce yes we did this
this game night thing mmm most of the
cast for space force was there and I was
winning it was tied between me and Steve
Carell mm-hmm and what we had to do was
go into our house and find some novelty
mug and then that would decide who won
so he and first thing I could think of
Conan was this does this look familiar
to you yes right you remember that yes
right and so I don't even I was so happy
and I just said this this is from
Conan's first year on late-night and
there wasn't even it didn't even say
Late Night with Conan O'Brien and I
don't have it and this is it but is that
right yeah I think so I think we we did
early on they weren't sure I was gonna
make it so they didn't want to put my
name on any of the mugs they just wanted
if another host took over they wanted to
just peel to to use the same mugs so yes
you're right I think that's from the
first season when pre-cut Priya my name
on anything and so did you win because
of that yes because it was TV history
like they all viewed it as okay that is
TV history back yes monumental yes but
then I woke up in the middle of the
night and I thought wait I wasn't on
Conan's show its first year but I think
you got a mug ha no I think we are
friends and you you visited and I think
you took one I'd you see right now
remember when you used to I don't know
if you want this out or not but used to
steal things take things a lot well
number me rephrase that in the 90s
you stole things and thanks
after the first year my name's Joey to
go on stuff I'm starting about a year
ago they started taking it off stuff
again it must be fun
getting to work with me it's a great
cast space force and you're working with
my old right
partner Greg Daniels this must be yeah
this is we used to all hang out in the
day back long time ago yeah Greg Daniels
is my writing partner and this is back
when I think you knew me when Greg and I
shared everything everything we shared a
car so if one of us got a date we had to
ask two but the other one to borrow the
car we shared an apartment we had desks
that faced each other at work and I
think after a year and a half we wanted
to kill each other we absolutely wanted
to kill each other have a sort of
preparation for right now yes that was
our preparation for this time we're
going through yeah warrant éand
after college together
[Laughter]